several emails came in about a
discussion I had a little bit earlier in
the week on bonds a guy called in said
he had 30,000 or 40,000 dollars tied up
in bonds and he wasn't talking about
savings bonds although I do recommend
cashing those in at all times and
putting them in a good investment but
bonds as a investment category I tell
him to get out of them and then another
call I had a lady call in that was
wanting to do all kinds of different
things and I suggested to her that she
invest that she you know she's wanting a
good safer calmer investment that she
put her money in growth and income and
balanced stock mutual funds balanced
stock mutual funds will have some bonds
in them in a rising interest rate
environment less and less bonds and
mainly large company stocks in a
declining interest rate environment
they'll go heavier into bonds but he
just kind of back up on this whole bond
thing for a second and just teach you
guys for a little bit to start with you
need understand what a bond is is it's a
debt instrument if you buy a ten
thousand dollar bond if it's a municipal
bond from a city that means that city
borrowed ten thousand dollars from you
they're in debt to you and they pay you
interest on the debt and then they repay
the debt
later at the call date when the bond
matures that's what a bond is and so if
you buy a corporate bond if you if a
company issued bonds they are borrowing
money from you it is a debt instrument
that's how it works and the financial
planning world has long said that if you
want to lower the risk of your portfolio
move towards bonds for instance as you
get older that you would move away from
stocks or equities and you're investing
in towards bonds I disagree with that
but see I think independently I don't
think like everybody thinks and and I
actually look at data and I actually
analyze things and and use critical
thought and here's my thought if you
take the bond market and plot
on a graph as it goes up and goes down
and you take the stock market and plot
it on a graph as it goes up and goes
down those mountains and those valleys
those peaks in those valleys on that
graph indicate the volatility of that
market over time and if you took say 50
years or 75 years of the stock market
you can see how the vault how the stock
market goes up and down over a period of
years and you could look at the bond
market and see how it goes up and down
over a period of years now something
that is safer would be less volatile if
it is so safe that we move an entire
population as it ages out of stocks and
into bonds you would think it would be a
lot less volatile and the truth is if
you take those two graphs and you lay
them over the top of each other there's
not a lot of difference bonds are less
volatile than stocks but not much and
they don't perform as well stock market
has outperformed the bond market over an
extended period of time and the
difference in the two honestly isn't
spit as far as volatility and so I you
know and the bond market doesn't perform
as well as the stock market has over
time as an investment for people now I
understand pensions play bonds and take
a bond position and I get all of that
but I'm talking about personal financial
planning to always say that you need to
move to bonds as you get older is to to
make the assumption and it's a it's a
bad assumption because it's incorrect
data that the bond market is
substantially less volatile than the
stock market and it's simply not it is
less volatile but not substantially less
volatile so here's what happens you need
to remember when you buy a bond let's
just do a very basic finance 101 class
for a second let's buy a ten thousand
dollar bond that has a 5% interest rate
while you own that 10,000 dollar bond
regardless of what you paid for it it's
going to pay you $500 a year 5% of
$10,000 that's what you're going to get
now as interest rates go up meaning that
people in the market that have money are
expecting to
get more money on their money because
interest rates have gone up if the if
you buy the bond in a five percent
interest rate environment and the
environment moves up meaning the
marketplace now to attract money five
percent will no longer attract money it
now takes six percent if prevailing
interest rates go from 5 percent to 6
percent your $10,000 bond is no longer
worth $10,000 unless you hold it all the
way to maturity because it is it you're
the market is saying we want 6 percent
and you only have $500 coming off of
this bond and $500 in order for that to
be 6% means I can't pay you but eight
thousand three hundred and thirty three
dollars for that bond if I want to make
6% on my money I can't pay you ten
thousand dollars for because I'm only
going to make five percent at that I can
only pay eight thousand three hundred
dollars which allows me to make my six
percent that I want so as interest rates
go up the value of your bond goes down
as interest rates go up the value of
your bond goes down because your
interest doesn't change on the bond it's
a fixed amount you're receiving and
people are now demanding a better rate
of return than your bond is offering so
your bond is now valued at less and so
as and you know we're talking about the
long-term bond market we're not talking
about speculating we're not talking
about jumping in and out on an hourly or
daily basis I'm talking about when
interest rates for mortgages which are
bond driven Fannie Mae bonds when
interest rates for mortgages are three
and a half and they move to four and a
half if you're holding a Fannie Mae
bonds you just lost some money even
though you haven't sold it yet it's like
owning a stock and a company and the
value of the stock goes down you just
lost money and while we were at a three
percent level in long-term bond rates
mortgage rates we're in here screaming
or the flip do you think these rates are
going from here these interest rates are
going to go up they're going to go up
and as they go up your bond values going
to go down consequently in the last 90
days people playing around in the bond
market people that do it for a living
I've got a good friend that's a bond
trader it's what he does for a living
and he has taken a bloodbath up I mean
just gotten hammered
got both his eyes black and his nose
broke I'm telling you it's bad just
because of that little move so many
basis points they call it in the bond
market and so you guys need to
understand I don't invest in bonds ever
but I particularly don't invest in them
on the markets down well Dave you just
turn around told that woman to get a
balanced fund yeah but that balanced
fund has already moved out of bonds
they're not going to be heavy in bonds
right now because they start looking at
what I'm talking about at a much more
sophisticated level then I just
explained it and so those two pieces of
advice are not at loggerheads with each
other they're not inconsistent so I buy
good growth stock mutual funds that's
what I've set for 22 years here on the
radio I've never told you to buy bonds
you